[Music]
this is you welcome with me [ __ ]
Marcela argüello today's guests are
David Bowie and carrot clink David has a
half-hour Comedy Central special airing
November 15th and Kara's an amazing
comedian and writer on RuPaul's Drag
Race so check them out follow them on
social media thanks for being here yeah
my friends how's everything what's new
Karen with the baby house that were
there work chugging towards the
six-month mark and oh wow but I just
took her on her first flight last week
oh how is that I didn't book a direct I
booked an insane person so I took her on
four flights no she can't even sit up
she can't could she roll over yeah okay
that's the girls over like a champ
oh yeah what's going on with you David
nothing I love it out here
no you're gonna be waiting I got a new
place David and I were roommates and it
was a nightmare I had to share a
bathroom with David Bowie
yikes [ __ ] [ __ ] if she perks me and she
at the same time you gotta give the
people what they want I know it's a fart
yeah he's right now you should fart and
show your feet you're gonna I get the
numbers up yeah get your own wiki feet
I'm on there I'm Raven okay someone told
me that's a good rating wait what what
worried when were your feet exposed on
television no it's not about television
it's like social media if you picture so
you think you're like at the beach yeah
look at my hotel isn't the singer they
[ __ ] they find it dude that's how you
do it alright quit no you gotta you have
to post pictures alright I'm going to
Mexico next week so you need to get on
wiki feed yeah that's the goal whatever
creep is following this and wants to
start a wiki for you guys for you I'm a
nine and a half but no that's not a big
13 okay like on there I mean
the market I bet there's a market for
the guys like for sure Tarantino he's
obsessed with feet yeah when I met him I
was like and I was wearing like my
converse and my feet just look like oh
yeah like they just look cute he was
like that's a wide based on yet you
don't see his boner through his pants
okay there was a tweet that went viral
by at the ELISA and she said this man
asked me out to coffee I don't do coffee
dates told him I do coffee for business
meetings and with friends happy to get
coffee with us friends she sent his next
text is asking me to dinner proper men
no they just want to see if they can
lowball you first do you think that's
true daven your man
David David feel like taking a lot of
straight weight on okay I think it is
true sometimes listen lowball and it's
great practice it in my daily life that
guy I don't think was low-balling her
though at all yeah I understand why she
would think that if he was kind of
lowball you he wouldn't go to coffee he
would go somewhere where he could
convert still right right like let's go
to the park yeah what that's what you do
yeah but like it's like he's not gonna
be like let's go to Starbucks at noon
where I get most of my sex like it's not
so but do you think that in a way though
that's like trying in like the era of
like me too and like stuff like that
that maybe you guys are trying to come
off as like I really want to get to know
you I don't want to like just take you
up for drinks and then bang you right
away like you know what they're trying
to appear more approachable and like
cool that's why you're married because
you're empathetic yeah maybe that's why
these [ __ ] are still single I think
that that's true I think though also the
dudes who weren't [ __ ] razor ramon or
whoever Marcela's into all other Z's
we're doing that always great weight
yeah like regular dude
that's what they do they're like I like
you I wanna want to go to coffee yeah
it's like the me goes who doesn't yeah
if and when you ask out women are you
low balling them like what's the
strategy there oh not anymore cuz I'm
not broke yeah we even when I was broke
though I tried to be like creative about
it I don't they'll be like let's go to
the zoo oh [ __ ] it's free zoo day for
everybody immoral that's creative oh
yeah oh good free zoo day if you live in
San Francisco the Botanical Gardens are
free if you live in the city or you can
get to that fence and I can get over it
so it's not like that yeah it's a strong
fence
yeah strong I like that
did Jared ever try to blow ball you at
the beginning no well we made out three
times at three different parties and
then I was like so see you again in two
weeks so you know bald yourself and then
he was like no I was being sarcastic and
he was like no no let's go out to dinner
so our first like date date was was
going out to dinner wasn't it
technically that first makeout party
yeah I didn't go home with him okay I
was upstanding girl I will say like I'm
I'm been married for a little while and
with him for a while so like a lot of my
dating is pre the apps I did do like a
harmony and stuff like that but it was
react no we are nice on religion is it's
Christian well but there was a big thing
on it where you could say spiritual but
not religious does not care about what's
right because they basically a harmony
was like a 17 tier system of questions
to get to a person it was exhausting
yeah and now they were like oh what if
we just cut that all out and it's just
[ __ ] moving your finger across
Henry's just like take your butter yeah
so but I will say like I would never go
on any first day that did involve
alcohol like if they were liver I would
like my sister was like this guy asked
me out to dessert once what like he just
asked her out to dessert like they just
got coffee and dessert and it was so
awkward cuz like I don't know in our 20s
we just wanted to have like a drink or
two but I've also been on drinks where
I've got a dates where I've gotten like
blacked out and then I go anywhere
because
I blacked out are you doing going away
yeah time's up Kara
time's up on me yeah so I I find with
that girl like in my 20s I'd be like
yeah [ __ ] the coffee date but now that
I'm now that I'm thinking about it like
I think it could have different meaning
yeah well yeah when you're older when
you're younger like you want a guy to
spend money on yeah well I mean I wasn't
even like the money thing I was just
kind of like let's get a drink I don't
want it to be awkward I want to sit
there and ask you about where you want
to be well I want to be a little bit
loose with your drink you know and like
one night darkness and what are you
gonna dress like do you want to do
comedy in the middle of the day you want
to accommodate up lark in the middle of
the day know you want to do it you could
what do you prefer to do it at night in
a club in darkness with like one drink I
guess yeah you would wait huge comedy is
dating have you ever been low-balled
when you're getting the dudes from I
could ever have so you just got out a
good way to meet a dude I'm just saying
I'm great in this scenario I'm just
saying Ice Cube is it gonna take you to
the Botanical Garden you know his son is
a fan of mine I bet he is oh I don't
date like I don't date I still don't
date I just like find you hook up with
and then maybe we'll go from there but
I'm like I've never cared about a like
how a guy takes me out or where he takes
me out I'm just like if we're hanging
out we're hanging out yeah and I also
don't mind paying but I like it's also
why I'm single this [ __ ] cuz I Anders
I've known I hope you paying for these
dude listen dude who's been paid
as he only means you harm I know but I'm
not looking for a long-term relationship
I'm like you know if the dick is good
I'll pay for the meal and dudes have low
standards on getting paid for it's like
I feel like I went on dates where I
split I've also gone out with guys who'd
like to spend money and they're
[ __ ] - so it's for me that's why I
can marry them but don't know Mary I'm
done so yeah I have no standards for men
that's really terrible food in your
pants yes they catch me horny or
something oh you are interesting even
though they're not
that's why catching me up here that
Magic Mike show it a bit of good who
really cares
honestly that's where everybody should
every single man should be just hanging
you wanna be outside of Magic Mike okay
and I'm horny when they leave that show
that's what you say until I'm hanging
out out front with a backpack what's up
did you like the show you go to the zoo
[Laughter]
so I wanted to talk about hecklers with
my guest today what is your worst
or maybe best experience with the
heckler I've had a lot of women it cost
me you know women are the worst and most
likely to be hecklers in my experience
my floor in a way yeah like yeah I've
had like I've definitely had show us
your dick wow really yeah what also you
said that to me
what so usually it was you know when I
didn't know her that well she thought it
was a funny bit but yeah especially
doing man are you kidding me yeah you
don't know her and like I'd be like oh
man Marcella she's like famous comics
she's from said and like I'd be at the
bar like trying to be cool then she'd be
like let me see your dick walk and then
you ended up moving in with her yeah she
showed me a dick everywhere
one time in Iowa I had I don't know how
to explain it it's like a big giant
woman who kept telling me she was gonna
take me home and then her husband who's
wearing all Cowboys gear from head to
toe like a cowboy I get it you get it
and they yeah they just they kept trying
to take me third time at 3 Way up a Fat
Boy three-way what No
here okay here's the crazy [ __ ] he was
tiny she was short and tight and stuff
yeah that's all the time here's one man
with the tiny little man but then a
third guy big dude trying to get
sandwich he likes this morning they
needed another piece of bread I was
putting out bread vibes I was wearing
shorts I asked for those sexual cash
yeah yeah but they were like she just
kept everything I said she would be like
and I was like and then I had that you
have to address it so I'm like are you
okay with that sir he's like whatever
she wants she gets
oh wow yes yep I don't think he was
though I don't think I had a choice yeah
I don't think he had a choice I think
yeah she was like I'm bringing him home
and you can watch yeah you Kara I
honestly like I was dreading this topic
because I don't have a lot of heckling
stories really I haven't been heckled a
lot I know that seems crazy but I
haven't had anybody be real like my
husband is a moth to the heckler flame
like they love him because he'd crowd
works a lot oh yeah he gets them like
all the time like I've seen him try to
hug a trump supporter like I've seen a
lot of like what chick well he like this
he and this guy were fighting and the
guy got really really at like agitated
and injera it's like why don't we hug it
out and he was like no that guy's yeah
where was that
Vermont comedy club oh I'm looking
forward to be there it's great it's the
best comedy club it's so good I love the
people that run it it's such a good
comedy club and they have security so
like they get up there
if there's like somebody heckling I
would say like one of my only heckles
was from another comedian I don't know
if you guys are familiar with me I seen
probably my Christine
very funny comic but also like an idiot
and he I was broken up with my husband
at the time we broke it up for six
months I was on a show where I was high
he was trying to [ __ ] no no no he was
dating my friend but he mean I had like
I had talked [ __ ] about Jared the night
before to him when I was drawing I like
said all this stuff so I'm on stage
today yeah and I'm on the next day I
thought this show that's a high show and
he yells out like save the Jared thing
or whatever are you [ __ ] like I think
I said the r-word book this it was 20 it
was 2011 Breaking Bad good strong word
yeah but I was like and and I was I
guess I count that as a heckle another
comedian being an [ __ ] yeah I mean I
do that to people do you get it all the
time are you kidding me I think it's so
crazy because like I don't get heckled
and you do more polite comedy that I do
oh that's what I'm saying I think it's
like not even I think it's like
embarrassing almost to say I don't get
heckled because it kind of assumes I
don't take a lot of risks you take a lot
of risks and then I think that's why you
oh that's why they Wow she went up there
with a kiss what a fight I'm friends
with Marcel and if I were in an audience
I would feel nervous to heckle you I
feel like yeah my kid might my head off
I got back what if she goes up I don't
want to yeah I was thinking surprised
that you get it a lot I had to do like
the 10 p.m. in Oxnard there was a chick
there that was timing there was just so
drunk from the beginning which is like
I'm already a bad sign yeah and it was a
table it was two women two men and they
of course the women were just like so
out of pocket and they want yeah women
are always screaming they are what we
are always screaming and [ __ ] be
scream [ __ ] be screaming and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] just being hell out of
pocket and I and I fight and and and cuz
I was talking [ __ ] to her because I was
like this [ __ ] is [ __ ] down like
drunk out of her mind but and the vet
the venue is still bringing the [ __ ]
drinks as I'm saying
she is out of control they're all
setting drinks down to her and I was
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
guys why are you bringing her more
drinks how desperate are you for money
yeah eventually she gets kicked out but
the thing is when she's getting kicked
out it looked like she was gonna charge
the stage and she was a big [ __ ] and I
was like oh and Lydia Popovich very good
community she was there with me opening
and she took her shoes off because she
was getting ready to charge on stage in
case she had to yo Lydia really is with
the [ __ ] with this [ __ ] but it was one
of those things where I was like I had
to like I was like oh my have to like I
might have to fight this [ __ ] and I was
like thinking about what shoes I was
wearing cuz I was all dressed up to
perform and although [ __ ] this is gonna
be tough what was your move gonna be if
she if she came out yeah your earrings
out of your ear so you don't live ripple
oh look exactly cantaloupe you gotta you
gotta you gotta get low with these
because I'm tall but she's a tall but
she's thin yeah so she doesn't shoe lot
there yeah it's different yeah so you
were gonna get low and tackle her yeah
no if I could the [ __ ] was big you's a
big [ __ ] she was a big [ __ ] and she's
the truth looking at she and I even said
like this but she's looking like she's
about to hit me yeah
and they finally escorted her out and
boy was I right because she waited for
you know oh she was outside hitting the
manager she was punching the manager oh
because the cops the [ __ ] was
handcuffed oh my god
yeah she was ready to [ __ ] fight me
he wanted the manager took those heads
yeah yeah yeah and it was a man so it
was good but yeah but man win-win yeah
exactly we have some questions to answer
and if you want any of your questions
answered about life love anything that
you need answers submit these questions
to you welcome questions at gmail.com
you guys ready for some oh hell yeah
watch how many dates do you wait before
you google investigate the person or do
you do it before investigate seeked I
figure David want to know what this is
about
like if you go out with somebody that
you don't really know like or you meet
them on tinder or whatever and I guess
you figure out their last name like
would you go thatif or you go on a date
out of women Google men because for
safety reasons yeah and they do
investigative research like what if
these yeah cuz men are predators
negative dates before yeah
I could have one day yeah for most women
they can't obtain a last name oh yeah a
man yeah you can no no David I'm pretty
good on the internet though I know I
mean you know I've nothing to hide you
really did no but yeah yeah they're
gonna be like boys of comedy central
chichi Google me ladies at the G is
silent david poori with the g my sister
we'd run background checks on guys to a
day before she was like lexis nexis [ __ ]
she would run background checks yeah yes
what so what could you find it like okay
so let's say if somebody had been in
trouble before but not like he's a good
guy David Bowie has been in trouble
before but he's a good guy yeah that's
the thing is you can figure it out you
kind of put it together you start
looking at their social media now
there's so much social media and like
the list if there's a criminal record
you know Mike you know can I say though
that I don't think no you can't say it
stop right there
I don't think I keep Congress with the
type of women who that's what you think
you have readily access to the internet
[Music]
dating mole women I listen I told small
she's getting it removed cuz he did bang
it off bro
man gross I really try to like be like
men are cool and then you literally look
at stuffed olives Instagram for one
minute and then you know that's why we
ran background checks he never knows do
you guys do that yeah but guys do it too
I had a guy on a date oh great it was a
second date he started quoting my jokes
to me he looked me up and watch the
night date but that's like you're a
public that makes more sense pretty new
into comedy
it was kind of weird that makes more
sense to me than like him bein like let
me see where she went to college you
know yeah but I guess that's like that's
how movies
are you doing it and my googling men
before yeah yeah let me see does he what
do you do time oh yeah I like them
saying shooing time I mean yeah I guess
it could be for safety it could be for
safety too but I think it's also just
like a general like oh what's the sky
like about I don't know like this is
this social media presents like ham on a
[ __ ] boat with a chain like was also
like you met her married yeah other
thing I've hooked up with married dudes
not knowing that they were married and I
was like oh but their social media
didn't show it either that's what when
you're a wife and you're not on your
husband's social media some women aren't
online the women that David David loves
the mole women alright these five women
mole women that's rude that's very rude
their names are Jessica they're all
named Jessica all named Jessica I've
been toying with the idea of doing
stand-up but where do I start out with
writing jokes what are some tips on
where to start first and finding your
pocket or your voice I'd be happy to
take you up for coffee and talk about it
there's a bunch of youtubers about it go
to a [ __ ] open mic quit asking people
yeah you know what I think we should do
you know the comp comedian John Roy yes
he has online like John Roy's comedy
school like he doesn't like that sure he
doesn't like that people get paid to
teach stand-up yeah he hates that so you
just put it all on the internet for free
great it's like all on the internet so
Google like John Roy's comedy school or
whatever and like he has all about like
how to go to Mike's and blah blah blah
it's like just general information but
you're saying you want no one to have
any help or handholds they go do it
that's what you did at the end of the
day that's what you did right but some
people don't know like where to go maybe
this isn't for you like a Republican you
go lift yourself from your bootstraps
yeah man maybe I'm asking for a
government handout
we'll stop asking for a David ant and
also what do you think I'm gonna tell
you you think I'm smart no I just went
to a million open mikes
okay okay but I I think the part of the
the question that I thought was really
good too was like about finding your
voice and stuff like she doesn't know
what to he
she doesn't know what to write jokes
about I might only be like write about
yourself beginning just write about
yourself like nobody needs to hear
you're like what's the deal with
everything bagels joke like at the
beginning you know like you just you
just my friend sham Torres is that a
joke that he does yeah why by the way
Shane Torres was at my wedding I love
him friends that's hilarious that is a
good answer I'm not gonna answer it yeah
I would say you know what I've uses to
help only the only advice I've given
people about writing stand-up or finding
your own voice is because the mistake
that a lot of young comics make is they
talk about sex obsessively yeah bad
language and I have told people if you
cannot talk about sex and you cannot
cuss you can find jokes that are yours
fast yeah I [ __ ] I'm scared of [ __ ]
you can talk about sex later yeah yeah
either but finding your voice is like
it's it's easier to get to if you try to
I don't say be clean but just attempt to
not be shocked really good advice yeah I
think that's very also because I think
also we both have seen a lot of like
Sarah Silverman wanna be easy stuff too
and like so don't try to meet that else
yeah yeah things I think that's where it
starts as you see some really great
showing love yeah cuz they do they have
great shock jock humor most comics that
they can write a good shock jokes if
they've been doing it for over ten years
but the problem is when a know a new
person attempted their do the boozy big
deal when you're young you're like you
know you're probably like 20 21 you're
fresh now you don't know yeah you're
like I'm saying dirty words in front of
adults like sure and when you're like a
year in the comedy like you're
definitely not reinventing the wheel all
right great you're not giving us
anything yeah ground break yeah that's
why it's like good to talk about yeah
talk about yourself your family your
life yeah that's not gonna sustain you
for an hour right like your snacks
points aren't probably
yeah that's not what the job is all
right and I'd also think cuz you're
assuming this person is young but I've
also oh yeah someone who starts later is
usually funnier
I started later I tell you that 27 yeah
usually people over 30 I think are
funnier immediately because they've
lived their life a little bit and so
they have more to talk about I never
understand what people are like this
comic is so awesome
she's 17 yeah like why do I care nothing
yeah like what is it what soccer
practice jokes what yeah I remember a
number they were like trying to push
this twelve-year-old on a women crush
Wednesday Zoar something and I was like
I don't want to hear her dad's jokes
yeah yeah yeah that's all that [ __ ] is
she's just saying her dad's yeah I'm not
no no thanks
that wraps our show thank you both Karen
and David follow them on social media
please we need it
yeah I'm not I don't I don't the G is
silent everyone the G is silent you
welcome [ __ ] peace out
[Music]